come on this way  all i can think about is  the banished gotta pay  [Applause]  more than a barracks  but there's more  over half of the banished detachment  manning this post are peeling off to  another excavation  we need eyes on the conservatory as soon  as possible i go myself but i need a  closer look at the artifacts here  at this time we've assumed  chief there's a high value target in  range the banished chieftain and get in  be careful if you go after him going by  his rap sheet he's pretty dangerous even  for a chieftain  target elimination confirmed but we're  not out of the woods yet finish off the  squad  you sure you want to do this last  mistake you'll ever make  we scared him off  lead the way  um  oh  [Music]  threat eliminated we just put down one  of the worst monsters to ever plague the  unsc